possible for that to be no if they had
to push tits and a net to a Christian
really yeah really
my wife's behind how'd they get I said
son no one really scared we she under
said that because I convinced myself
that it would do it well it also could
read go jam kill me if it's going to end
it with someone's targeting this is
black that's quite too much might be
that's just fortunate eventually the
total since what each don't mean
anything what we do is make it scary so
that's a possible future event says
actually see a good fortune was standing
up covered in blood
which make sure three something
something justice can be then nothing's
kidding me just amazed this it's just
remember wages just keep on the tracks
well we have to try to get forward
somehow you know chance will dig it out
this looks like a way out status it
sounds good
just like you can see what I do know
this game the bad guy I think people and
I think that they know each other
I don't know ideally the flame thrower
London I think I don't really annoying
they do it and it's really quick each
one that stuff how impressive not
graphics it's really but yeah she's in
the way whoo
she hurts the screen and I can't see are
you doing - I'm not controlling her and
then trolling him dance God woman get
out of the way just what are you doing
I got a choice we just yeah but did you
not say that something should pop up
boom didn't see it did he said I did
never did he
yes and we stopped using it so that
wasn't fun let's just move so this fish
we can remember
it was it wasn't yeah which one do you I
think
got a lot of lucky good luck out there
good match yeah that's supposed to be
he's close to yeah yeah I feel like he
probably could be but it's just great
game guys should maybe you should be a
game review yeah
water running on 0 10 yeah realistic
she climbed too long it's not that
interesting
okay she's gonna be couple times - yeah
she's going yeah I was thinking this
side she's okay what happened don't know
she just Frank terrible time to club
there what happened
what you only do just look up the hot
water just when we get them fast
I'm here so this is Sam we likes it we
want sin don't want Sam to die
Wanda in his she's her and that the only
ones like really kill it Mets nonce gone
miss it yeah she just sounds to me no no
no no she just said whoa what was that
but I didn't hear anything what was that
what are you referring to everything's
getting creepy
with a tattoo studio Shawn turn it
jo han be smooth Teddy what a steal
March 18th 2014
and one of that's much beautiful it's
not your heart of course basement so as
much city she's a sweet birthday present
obviously times room
okay something a little bit it's kind of
creepy concerns even okay that's pretty
cool
just a cool room damn rich family
employers don't know so did you enter
correction like maybe mostly C's this is
tested she's filled out about Mike gun
she was like a crazy breakfast at hunk
of a man who's thinking about working
with your boy degree and practicing do
you mind on the piano would be something
really wild my way from quite will get
at utter she was gonna get a tattoo to
impress Mike Oh gross and that magazine
is disgusting don't get tethers to
impress boys it's terrible that makes it
even worse that they pulled that
Franklin over because maybe they knew
that she had a crush on hits really old
sex these people suck
she really likes Mike they used to that
yeah they doing this
that's the right across so now everyone
can you gonna help so she was already
across the national photo should be
she's certainly reacting to the sisters
she's not reacted to show so can it take
the yes which would be weird anything
no I think that was ultra stung supposed
to be referencing each other like trying
to build on the fact that she had a
crush on Mike because we didn't already
know that so that being stood a this is
the tenth largest she was going to come
yeah to prove that she's gonna get had a
good to impress yeah yeah so as he did
you know dick you're terrible and Red
Bull full magazines
what they did here this one think so
look it could be everything in this game
is creepy
even nothing's gonna I think he's gonna
get Sam to do it unless it makes me take
this okay that's always nice
it actually has only let me control a
small amount of people so far I think
it's my first time my second time I'm
feeling sad it's all to sit on unique
Italy control different people or
different places like anyone well I
think it's an interesting way of
storytelling are you seeing that
person's innovative every time you do it
and it's looking backwards and forwards
yeah it's not too different from a film
the way that that cut was from the
cabinet to here oh my gosh
hmm and I just go for it
so paradise it's not gonna happen
that's a weird thing to say he's old
yeah I didn't like that you know like
Josh no I didn't like you me that I
think he's really pissed being told me
you've gone to his head because there's
a part in this game ah that I submitted
what is she still on oh there is
it's weird to do everything if do the
check go which what do you think I'm
thinking that is reassuring because I
think he knows that he was action was ok
as anything it was okay well what are
choosing her answer to him like so he's
over she has to either reassure him
Hotel okay okay yeah yeah so this thing
that I'm thinking about right now is
positive this thing that I played the
demo where I'm sure gonna try to spoil
too much but Chris at one point
literally hasn't gone to his head in a
situation that relates to Ashley as well
and so the fact that Josh just said that